There are ten lessons in this course,
and
they correspond with the ten
chapters in the text.
We've split Lesson 5 into two
sections because of its length.
While the material is not
generally technically difficult,
there is a lot of it.
More in fact than can be
covered in the lectures.
So reading the text and
the other suggested materials is key.
Lessons 1 and 2 provide background on
US healthcare delivery and the role of
federal government is playing to foster
adoption of information technology.
Lessons 3 through 5 cover the core
technologies that all contemporary
health informatic systems and
tools rest on.
Lessons 6 through 8 show how health
informatics is being used in real world
applications, from electronic records
for providers and patients, to
managing the health of large populations
of patients over an entire region or
state, to understanding and
improving public health.
Lessons 9 and 10 show how data can
be aggregated from these systems and
analyzed to gain new knowledge and
even improve the healthcare
system that generated the data.
During this course we'll hear from
experts in various segments of
the field.
It should help you see
how the knowledge and
concepts you're learning
are actually being applied.
Along the way you'll be able to test
your knowledge with frequent quizzes.
So I want you to get use
to that interactive format.
Let's try out an easy
question right now.
Which of these fields involves
the use of computing?
Health informatics,
Bioinformatics, Both or Neither.